هكذا يوثق حزب الله عملياته ضد الاهداف
العسكريه الاسرائيليه على الحدود تلك جبهه
فتحها الحزب في اليوم التالي لاندلاع
الحرب في قطاع غزه يوم السابع من اكتوبر
صحيح ان الحزب لم يعلن خوض المعركه بكل
قوته مع اسرائيل الا انه يستخدم صواريخ
نوعيه ابرزها صاروخا بركان وفلق الكبيران
نسبيا يؤكد الامين العام لحزب الله ان ما
يقوم به الحزب يشكل ضغطا عسكريا على
اسرائيل ويشغل ثلث قواتها خلال الشهور
الثلاثه الاولى من هذه المواجهه يقول حزب
الله انه نفذ قرابه 700 ضربه ضد الاهداف
الاسرائيليه وفق اعلان الحزب فانه استهدف
48 موقعا ونقطه عسكريه اسرائيليه بالاضافه
الى استهداف 17 مستوطنه على الحدود تلك
حدود تمتد الى قرابه 140 ك مت من راس
الناقوره غربا الى الجولان السوري المحتل
شر شرقا خلال المئه يوم الاولى من هذا
الصراع جرح اكثر من 2000 اسرائيلي بضربات
حزب الله ولم تعلن اسرائيل عن عدد واضح
للقتلى والجرحى في صفوف جنودها لا يعترف
بقتله ولا يعترف بجرحا يتهمها حسن نصر
الله بانها تخفي حقيقه هذه الخسائر تشير
معلومات حصلت عليها الجزيره من مصدر امني
لبناني الى ان عمليات اجلاء للاصابات تتم
باستمرار من المواقع العسكريه الاسرائيليه
مستهدفه لكن بالبحث والمتابعه لا يتم
الاعلان في اسرائيل بشكل رسمي عن وقوع
اصابات او قتلى على الحدود الشماليه عل
لهذا التكتم الاسرائيلي اسبابه المتعلقه
بمقاربات مختلفه لجبهه لبنان عما هو الحال
في جبهه غزه فاعلان اسرائيل الرسمي لعدد
القتلى من الجنود على الحدود الشماليه قد
يرفع الاصوات المطالبه بوقف الحرب على
الجبهتين او رفع الاصوات بالدفع نحو جبهه
لبنان بشكل اوسع لاذا زاله خطر حزب الله
وهو ما يلمح اليه القاده السياسيون
والعسكريون الاسرائيليون لكن يبدو ان تل
ابيب لا تريد خوض حربين بنفس المستوى في
ان واحد وهي تعلم ان قدرات حزب الله تفوق
قدرات حماس بشكل ملحوظ يزور وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي قواته على الحدود الشماليه ومن
هناك يرسل تهديدات واضحه لحزب
الله اذا كان حزب الله يعتقد انه عندما
يكون هناك وقف لاطلاق الار في الجنوب
فاننا سنوقف اطلاق النار في الشمال اذا
اوقف هو ذلك فانه يرتكب خطا كبيرا اقول
بصراحه طالما اننا لم نصل الى وضع يمكن
فيه عوده سكان الشمال بامان فلن نتوقف
اكذا تضغط الحدود بين لبنان واسرائيل
لتتحول الى جبهه مفتوحه اكثر مما هي عليه
الان تفعل ذلك في تبادل اطلاق النار
الجاري بهذا المستوى بين الطرفين وقد تفعل
اكثر اذا ما قررت اسرائيل من داخلها تغليب
صوت الحرب على صوت
الهدوء